The road to freedom starts here.
Netflix has just dropped the full-length trailer
for El Camino: A Breaking Bad Movie, which
stars series favorite Aaron Paul back in his
role as Jesse Pinkman.
The film picks up some time after Jesse made
his great escape from a band of Neo-Nazis,
known as Jack's White Supremacist Gang, in
a stolen El Camino during the Breaking Bad
finale.
From there, El Camino follows Jesse as he
attempts to evade imprisonment and forge a
new life far different from the one he experienced
alongside notorious meth cook Walter White
- played by Bryan Cranston.
While the trailer is jam-packed with a ton
of intriguing imagery, returning characters,
and a whole slew of teaser-y clips, it's a
short exchange near the end that has our interest
most piqued.
"You ready?"
"Yeah."
So, who exactly was Jesse talking to at the
end of the El Camino trailer?
We have an idea.
To us, it sounds like the disembodied voice
belongs to Ed, otherwise known as the Disappearer
- the vacuum cleaner repairman whom Walter
White called after Jack's White Supremacist
Gang murdered his brother-in-law Hank Schrader
and Hank's partner at the DEA, Steven Gomez,
during season 5.
After Walt left his family behind, Ed gave
him a new identity, gathered all the documents
he'd need to start with a clean slate, detailed
how to get to his safe house in New Hampshire,
and warned him that he'd be caught and likely
killed if he left the premises.
"You got two acres up here, lots of woods,
nice, warm place.
Seems to me just the spot for a man to rest
up and think on things."
Ed is obviously an expert at giving criminals
new lives, so it's not unreasonable to think
that Jesse might seek the same service in
El Camino.
After all, it isn't like Jesse and Ed don't
know about each other: on season 5 of Breaking
Bad, Walt's shady lawyer Saul Goodman arranged
to have Ed "disappear" Jesse, but Jesse backed
out of the plan in the 11th hour.
Maybe now that he's truly desperate for freedom,
Jesse will reach out to Ed and ask for help.
However, there's the chance that the man is
someone else - with popular guesses being
the former crooked cop Mike Ehrmantraut who
is confirmed to be in El Camino, or Walter
White himself.
However, the voice in the El Camino trailer
doesn't really sound like Mike or Walt.
Plus, Breaking Bad made it pretty obvious
that the two men are dead.
If you'll recall, on the Breaking Bad episode
"Gliding Over All," Mike's body can be seen
in the trunk of Walt's car, and Walt says
that it was necessary for him to shoot Mike.
"I don't want to talk about this."
"Okay."
"It had to be done."
And on the series' finale, Walt suffered gunshot
wounds in a shoot-out with Jack's White Supremacist
Gang, ultimately succumbing to his injuries
on the floor of a meth lab.
Though, it is worth noting that we didn't
see a body bag - so there is a chance that
Walter survived the carnage.
That considered, it's possible that the El
Camino trailer is purposefully misdirecting
us.
The voice we hear in the last few seconds
may very well belong to a random person and
could have been dubbed in during post-production
to throw fans off, catching their attention
and sparking speculation without revealing
the true identity of the man Jesse was talking
to.
This type of trickery is not at all uncommon
- movie trailers lie to us all the time - and
would be a smart move to make when it comes
to the highly-anticipated El Camino.
Of course, with Breaking Bad creator Vince
Gilligan having revealed that El Camino features
more than 10 characters from the beloved drama
series, there's also a chance that the mystery
man is someone we're just not thinking of
yet.
Whomever Jesse Pinkman was seen talking to
in the final moments of the El Camino trailer,
one thing seems obvious: Jesse
is about to embark on a mission, and the mystery
man is involved in some capacity.
All that we can do for now is wait patiently
for the much-anticipated film to answer all
of our burning questions when it premieres
on Netflix on October 11th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.